this is the Fox News Alert President
Trump has unveiled his strategy for
national security one that enshrines his
America first campaign approaches a US
policy in an address at the Ronald
Reagan Building in Washington the
president outlined a plan that includes
defeating Isis protecting the US from
North Korea and securing our borders
among other topics the president also
spoke about leaving a greater America to
our children and our grandchildren watch
on top of everything else our leaders
drifted from American principles they
lost sight of America's destiny and they
lost their belief in American greatness
On January 20th 2017 I stood on the
steps of the Capitol to herald the day
the people became the rulers of their
nation again American success is not a
foregone conclusion it must be earned
and it must be won together we will
leave our children and our grandchildren
a nation that is stronger better freer
prouder and yes an America that is
greater than ever before ok Greg I know
you're gonna say so I can't call on you
right now Dana well a national security
strategy is something that is
congressionally mandated but it's a
president's can wait a couple three
years even before they do something and
I think that any president that puts out
a plan like that's the plan until
breaking news changes everything right
which is you know you never know what's
going to pop up in the world and every
problem in the world ends up on the
President's desk there's two things that
I really liked about it and in
particular you're gonna see a push about
this next year and we need to talk about
it more which is military readiness and
the sich the the state of our military
the repairs that are needed for our
planes and new planes that are needed
the new equipment and also all of the
cyber security issues that we're dealing
with the president touched on that a
little bit and I think you'll see a push
in the new year especially when it comes
to funding the other thing that I like
hearing him say was that as a force for
good throughout its history America will
use influence its influence to advance
our interests and benefit humanity and I
think that really does keep us separate
from other countries in the world that
we are exeptional for a reason and that
really is the main reason alright so you
liked it I mean that definitely themes
you thought about American
exceptionalism I mean I thought of it
made sense to me like protecting the
homeland yeah I get it
American prosperity if America is doing
better economically that means that you
have more money in the world and more
influence and will meant more money to
pay for military readiness in order to
protect the country and also the
economic freedom is a part of that
preserved peace through strength and
advanced American influence if you were
just reading it that way you could say
any president over the past you know 200
years could have had similar things
sounds like Reagan a bit though when he
talks about it and you heard an excerpt
of the first half of the speech was
really going through the list of
accomplishments that he thinks he's had
over this past year and then he got to
the strategy so it all fitted together
at the end but for me the two things
that stood out the most was military
readiness which we know we have a huge
problem with and that has to get fixed
and the second piece being this saying
that we will continue to be a force for
good in the world which the world needs
which it that most definitely ok Greg
you heard some different things as well
in there no I heard kind of the same
things I mean I I guess I'm always tired
of hearing it's always about the
children right but I'm ok with that
this is the central piece of his agenda
it I called it the stool of security so
it's a table with three legs one of them
is national security dealing with our
enemies and adversaries like Isis in
North Korea then you have domestic
security which is basically
reinvigorating the way the country feels
and appreciates law enforcement because
we saw them disrespected for so long and
then the third is the border which is
linked to the above the border becomes
more valuable in terms of national
security when you have terrorism and you
have technologies so that's an important
since that those are the three legs on
this stool but the big point here is
somewhere along the line as government
grew we lost the plot what is government
for primarily this without this that
this this stool of security you don't
have freedom or prospects
security and strength guarantees freedom
and prosperity then the last thing
politically is that if you don't like
Trump or political or like you you just
couldn't get in you just couldn't accept
him this is the kind of agenda that
makes you overlook the small stuff that
bugs you you know what I mean if you've
said this before if somebody is right on
the big picture you can forgive or
overlook the smaller more embarrassing
Polaroids you know so what if he tweets
and there's always this kind of
underlying underlying chaos and conflict
if somebody is right on the big picture
it doesn't matter and when we look back
we will we will realize that it didn't
matter no one will remember a lot of
this stuff but we will remember the
strong military and enhance security and
no terrorism all right well great points
because immigration and Border
Protection are also key components of
President Trump's new national security
strategy watch this leaders in
Washington imposed on the country an
immigration policy that Americans never
voted for never asked for and never
approved a policy where the wrong people
are allowed into our country and the
right people are rejected American
citizens as usual have been left to bear
the cost and to pick up the tab a nation
without borders is not a nation okay
Jesse a reaction to this I think he was
trying to strike a very clean break from
pass administrations by saying he's here
to ignite a reawakening in American
confidence and usher in a rebirth of
pride and patriotism and prosperity by
putting America first and putting the
people above the powerful and American
greatness has to be guarded vigilantly
because our destiny is not assured and
he tried to inspire all the American
people to be competitive in a new
competitive world and pointed out China
and Russia as other great nations that
are trying to seize what we have and
then he pointed to all the litany of
failures from past administrations
taxpayers bailing out other alliances
jobs being fleeced by overseas out of
countries spending a lot of blood and
treasure on wars where we tie and he
went along that list but then like Greg
said pointed out to the four pillars
protect the homeland and you just heard
them border security and that's the wall
that's reinforcing our great Border
Patrol agents and that's getting rid of
things like chain migration and the visa
lottery also defeating Isis and make
sure they can't come over here
but then promoting peace and prosperity
and that's through cutting taxes and
cutting regulation and not signing bad
trade deals where workers get hoes and
big companies make out great and then
preserving peace through strength
talking about huge reinvestment in our
military but also focusing on modern
threats like missile defense and cyber
and then at the end he kind of tweaked
President Obama he's trying to focus on
realism not idealism where we're not
going to try to impose our way of life
on other people and we're not going to
lead from behind and said we're gonna
champion our values and I think he
believes that that's the best
opportunity for us to maintain our
number one posture he loved being number
one Jesse okay so did you hear this
through the same prism that Jesse did
not at all I certainly agree with Jesse
that he was playing against you know
grievance politics going at all the
presidents who came before when in fact
this I think I think somebody else on
the panel maybe you Dana said it could
have been any other president this is
basically in keeping with our national
security framework but where it differs
and to me he identified it so you got to
give him credit for that is that China
and Russia are exerting increasing
evidence that they want to increase
their profile in the world globally so
to me if you look at Asia where we
backed out of the Asian trade deal
I see China stepping up and it's not
only stepping up in terms of economics
but militarily
similarly Russia in the Middle East
given what happened in Syria but also
with Iran you see Russia playing a
bigger role so Trump identifies that but
he then doesn't say exactly how we will
respond
to the contrary he says we're going to
be more focused on our interest and our
security excited well of course he's
going to focus on our security but I
don't see that we are taking the
necessary steps to fight back against
Russia and China's growing influence in
the world I was out at that Reagan
Library the other day for the National
Defense forum and this is what the
defense experts are saying is that you
know there's a lot of talk from Trump a
lot of rhetoric but no action in terms
of saying here's what our Middle East
policy was going this is this is he is
reprioritizing the number one threat
isn't Russia the number one threat is in
China it's existential terror that's
that's the ball that he sees these other
things are behind that ball and he will
deal with them and maybe they can help
maybe Russia can help with terror that's
what he's looking when you look at that
when you look at it from that angle
that's what happened I don't agree with
you net by the way there was an
interesting phone call over the weekend
between Trump and Putin where where
Putin thanks apparently Trump for
intelligence that warded attack that
would have taken place in st. Petersburg
but I don't think that's a terror is the
number one issue here if you're talking
about our national security structure
right I think you are talking about the
possibility that terror would be
generated in a place like the Middle
East especially after what he did with
Jerusalem well president Trump also
addressed a strategic goal of the US
which was destroying Isis we have dealt
Isis one devastating defeat after
another the coalition to defeat Isis has
now recaptured almost 100 percent of the
land once held by these terrorists in
Iraq and in Syria great job we're now
chasing them wherever they flee and we
will not let them in to the United
States
okay so focus there on national security
obviously on border is a strong
immigration policy peace through
strength Dana echoes in the comments you
made earlier about former president's
past presidents really focusing on this
kind of Reaganesque theme and then here
using a specific example topic sentence
Isis right well I do think that the
technology
has advanced so much in just in 16 years
and one of the things that you can do is
shrink Isis's territory okay you can
even prevent them from getting in here
but we have shown em just in the last
month that we continue to have a problem
with online radicalization so Isis is
able still to put things up online to
try to figure out a way to get to people
and the president is saying okay well
the first thing we have to do as a part
of America first is figure out a way to
use the tools that we have in order to
prevent that from happening
he doesn't spell it all out in here and
you can't in a National Security
document a lot of this stuff has to be
classified but I do think that he will
have to have quite a strong push and
probably you'll see it in the State of
the Union that military readiness which
includes
dealing with possibilities of biological
terror online terror attacks like
cyberattacks and then you had somebody
like China just to pull this all
together as one was talking about this
morning China released an for its
government to be the number one
artificial intelligence creator and
technology developer in the world for
David so they are like way ahead in
terms of that type of planning and we
don't want to be playing second fiddle
to that so there's a lot that's gonna
happen and I think of this next year is
how you set the stage for how are you
going to provide the resources to our
military and intelligence forces in
order to do that military readiness
technology those resources 700 billion
dollar investment that's a historic
investment in the US military and to
Juan's point
I mean he's ripped up the rules of
engagement which allowed us to destroy
the Caliphate over there no artificial
timelines in Afghanistan the Iran
Revolutionary Guard is now labeled as a
terrorist organization that bad deal is
also in the crosshairs and the North
Korea situation major sanctions slapped
on them so to say that the president
isn't really doing anything or hasn't
really spelled out how he's doing it one
you want to remain unpredictable but two
I think there's a lot of leather out
there no I I watched I can't wrote what
Sunday show yesterday it was pretty
funny they were interviewing some dude
some expert and he was talking about
beginning about how Trump had a bad year
Trump out a bad year except for Isis
except for Isis economy's doing pretty
good and you may get attacked making
attacks on the judges but in a really
bad year and another
yeah except for Isis it's like if all he
did was Isis that's a pretty damn great
here and by the way you know I mean we
had other news today about I don't know
how much how true it is but if you know
what a difference from Obama who gave a
pass to Hezbollah I'm not sure if that's
true but it's all it's something that
maybe we should look into I think you
guys should pick up a copy of a
newspaper and in it it would say oh my
gosh look President Bush President Obama
all of these people were fighting terror
all along that's what you say I mean
that's just you know empty what's it in
Politico yes all right so it wasn't
crazy
there was current political gonna have a
big thing on it tonight that very story
so there you go the bomb tease Deepti